this guide is known as a finisher
people choose to stand and bang with
this man they go to sleep
he felt and I'm moving up to the
division
this man is an absolute monster in
welterweight
the biggest fight in welterweight
history
[Applause]
it's freezing it's raining we can't
control the weather and I apologize to
the fighter we flew out we flew him all
the way from Orlando Florida to
Calabasas California he is the face of
bare knuckle boxing he's coming off a
huge win against Michael Van and Paige
it's the one the only Mike Perry on this
week's food truck Diaries and I'm
feeling my favorite of all time Cousins
Maine Lobster rolls let's go
[Music]
I need everything I get super thick boy
used to have a model [ __ ] now I got a
thick one yeah I do last night went late
yeah we had a sick one not very drunk
yeah and I like Mr Mike Perry
what's up big dog how you doing brother
great man how have you been since you
knocked out Miracle Crow cup that was a
hot second ago uh CTS catch up with him
I'm doing my best I have four more years
of this and then it's just everything's
gonna go to the Wayside I don't think
I'm good now
it's a struggle brother I'll lose my
keys Mike here we go
um dude but you you're crushing it man
you're one of the guys I think the it's
an inspirational story because you know
you get cut by the UFC and I think a lot
of people probably doubting you right
like if you listen a lot of chatter
online it's like oh we're never gonna
hear from uh Perry again right and then
you sign with bear knuckle I'm like
that's interesting I bet he's gonna do
pretty well in that and your undefeated
bare knuckle and then out of the
freaking blue I remember I was on the
road or somewhere I think it was me and
theater together we get the notice that
you're fighting Michael Venom page I'm
like where'd this come from how'd that
fight come about
um I gotta say man bare Knuckles talking
real money
they they're offering much more than
I've ever
seen in my entire life now is it set up
I don't interrupt you but is it set up
the same as UFC like show and win money
or is it just straight up fight it's
boxing money how do you like I show up
and I get money and no matter win or
lose with the MVP fight I got paid
regardless and then there was a little
bit of a win bonus on top of that
so
um did that fight come out for you did
it come out of the blue because it
sounds like it was it just you know he's
under contract with Bellator I know
Scott Coker I know Scott well and he's
always down for some wild things but
that came out to me out of left field
yeah I had no idea that that was going
to happen and it's I'm curious because
like you know when I left the UFC I
finished my contract uh I was told UFC
would resign me
um but I would have had to wait and I
was ready to fight yeah and I was ready
to you know get a check and try to
compete and win and when you're taking
multiple offers like Bellator like
everybody Bellator wasn't on the table
actually Bellator didn't want to talk to
me
um pfl I guess as far as I knew and um I
know pfl was out there and pfl might be
gunning for me now yeah
um I bet but the bare knuckle just
seemed like the right fit they had the
right offer uh the opportunity was there
and then when the MVP fight came up I
got a little more out of my contract
with them and um like when your manager
called you like all right we got a fight
and I love that you know because
Bellator didn't want to look out for me
uh when I was leaving UFC he beat up
their cast um yeah they sent out their
Cash Cow to find me a bare knuckle and I
was like all right so now I where's the
offer for me to fight in MMA in Bellator
for a big check like that but you know
when
when people were talking trash like oh
Perry's out of the UFC
but when Michael Phantom page was
fighting me in Bellator they're like oh
shout out Scott Coker letting him do
this like where's his next fight yeah
where's he where he's he back in
Bellator or was it all Bs and it was
just a bunch of media BS you know and
when you got uh called to fight my
Covenant page obviously a talented
Striker I mean one of the best we have
in all the land that dude is a bad man
you know was there now it's not MMA it's
not straight up box it's not straight up
kickboxing it's bare knuckle boxing
which you clearly had an advantage with
that because you just you know you made
a war I don't think he was ready for
that I think he underestimated you and
you made a warranty it's an interesting
style did he go through your head kind
of MMA kind of but it's bare knuckle
punching and it lets you focus on just
your boxing yeah he likes to box I like
the box that's obviously why he took it
he thought he could outbox me he thought
he's just gonna light up a brawler
he showed me a couple tricks I saw some
things that I didn't see coming like he
teleported one time and hit me from
across the ring I was like yeah Chris
Tucker I was like getting up like how'd
you do that like which one of y'all hit
me yeah but then you you wobbled him
and you know straight out the gates and
then I you know I tried to keep wobbling
them from there I just stay in your face
going into the fight did were you
confident fighting like of course my my
whole thing with you know fighting
lately has been about
confidence believing in myself the work
and and not just like overworking myself
over training really just kind of laying
back and being like look this is gonna
happen so I make sure that I'm ready for
it when I get in there it sounds like
you're feeling great sounds like you're
more of a professional now right that's
a good way to be more mature well
where's the Big Show at to take on one
of the biggest professionals out here in
Combat Sports I agree with you I'm
surprised Bellator hasn't offered you uh
come on or UFC UFC's not gonna do it I
know that you're not going to do a
problem for UFC right now which doesn't
make sense to me but meaning the money
that you're getting from bare knuckle
yeah you you'd want them to match up
Jake Paul's people told me the same
thing the money I'm making right now is
an issue interesting
um when these people have the pockets to
fill it
um I guess they're just doing business
but my management team is not the type
of team that is listening to this BS
they know what I'm worth and they know
what they can get for me and out of me
so so I guess my question would be like
who gives a [ __ ] about the UFC or
Bellator or Jake Paul the problem is if
you're making all the regular people
love [ __ ] UFC yeah but your bank
account does no regular people there's
no cats very true yeah my family needs
what I'm getting now and and I
definitely love the advantage I almost
feel like it's a cheat code bear and
Uncle Mike Perry like I could [ __ ]
beat anybody and you and I think what's
special about it too you know and you'll
see you're a small fish in a big pond
it's the biggest pond belt toward
smaller Pond but still bigger
organization bkfc newer you're kind of
the face of it now about May weather
promotions put some gloves on my hands
boxing I mean I'm boxing now and bare
knuckle don't get me wrong like bare
knuckle boxing has taught me and has
made me much better with gloves on
boxing gloves yeah I love boxing I've
always loved the box and I love what I
wear shout out to Styles make fights SMF
they're out this way and Cali and they
make sure I look amazing every time I
enter the ring and you know the GSP used
to say it you know like uh when you look
good looking good all that yeah so I go
out there feel that swag you know what I
mean I feel you but aren't you there has
to be something kind of your loyalty to
be KFC because they're giving they give
you that big opportunity Michael Lennon
page now you're kind of you're the
poster boy for Bare knuckle fighting
what's next that's what I'm saying so
it'll probably be on bear knuckle and I
heard the owner bear knuckle talk about
we'd love to have Nate Diaz over right
try and send a Nate Diaz fight right
um I've heard you know he's not gonna do
that
um yeah I don't think he will he's
probably gonna fight Jake Paul right
make all the money in the world
maybe I mean I don't think he has the
box in the fight either of us to be
honest with you Jake did pretty good
against Silva he fights very smart very
scared but very smart and um you know
I just I love you know I would love to
box anybody out here because I can I
love throwing these hands yeah I feel
like you're only getting better you know
the I am getting your UFC run is fun
you're always exciting fighter I got a
bunch of fights on the nights and it's
confusing for me though correct the UFC
was confusing so uh with the Mixed
Martial Arts all the training the
grappling uh the Jujitsu and when I get
in the ring I just want to punch people
I did rounds and rounds and rounds and
rounds of grappling I'm a very great
Grappler I'm so good yeah you never saw
really anyone give me problems except
when I took Cowboy down yep so
um and now I just box and focus on I'll
go to the MMA gym with my boxing and I
just brawl and sprawl yeah it works out
perfectly so certified anyone yeah so
when it comes to that I know you talked
about getting back to the UFC to even
want it sounds like you're happy at bare
knuckle because you because you don't
have to focus on the other assets I want
the
the you know the pride and the eyes yeah
and I want people to give me some
[ __ ] respect you don't you don't
think you got after my Governor page
no interesting unfortunately no and I
don't think that we had very many eyes
on us I was there you know what I mean
but it's like it wasn't what we
what a fight that was and that's what
makes me curious about the Bellator like
why
isn't that on the table like me and
Michael Venom page fight in MMA because
his legs are very dangerous
maybe it you know are they protecting
microphone and page though like if he
loses to you again then you know because
that's her that's their boy right that's
the one of the faces of the building why
would you protect anyone in the sport of
fighting to let the sport speak for
itself yeah well you're talking about
purist you're talking about appearance
but they're business right so like right
I don't understand the business yeah I'm
real yeah I fight and that's it yup he's
pretty damn good at it I also think when
when you're in the UFC you know you know
that's you're a bit of a wild boy you
know that's some issues everyone had
issues but I feel like and I I told you
this when we met I said uh I feel people
I feel sorry for people that are
fighting Michael Michael uh Perry now
because you know once you had a kid that
stuff tends to get put to the Wayside
you mature and it's more about your
family and your kid and it just happens
every fighter fighter comic podcaster
whoever it is any any business you get
more focused after you have kids unless
you're just a bad person but you're a
bad person
after having a kid you know I lost a
decision and but like I don't know where
the winning came from it's just my
mindset changed I left to a difference
where I've always been more of a boxer
than anything yeah I always just want a
box a punch so once they gave me that
opportunity to be who I wanted to be you
flourished I just tried to take over
yeah yeah man so yeah if I'm you I just
take over bare knuckle what you're doing
you're the face nobody wants to fight me
and that [ __ ] Bring It On yeah but
there's a couple of nobodies in there
who might want some attention that's
fine they didn't even send them my way
the champion this guy who [ __ ] stole
from me I paid him to hook up my car I
got a Skyline and I paid him to hook it
up I got this court thing going with him
right now and he's the [ __ ] champion
and he's gonna fight some guy who beat
Julian Lane by Split Decision who this
guy David Mondale I fought twice in my
life I beat him both times and
I beat Julian and like the the offer
didn't come my way interesting
but my management does what they do
because they know the business that I
don't yeah well that's why you hire them
right that's why you're doing percentage
but I feel like maybe the reason we're
not hearing something is because there's
something big coming you know what I'm
saying I would assume behind closed
doors they're trying to get something
rolling yeah well I'll tell you what's
big comment is this lobster roll it's my
favorite food truck in La so you're not
allergic to shellfish no that'd be a
disaster this was not cheap uh make sure
you eat as much Lobster as you can so
let me feed you some Lobster and
continue this talk brother sounds good
are you a lobster roll fan absolutely
I've had some good ones in Miami that's
what these are gonna be better than any
of those Miami ones let's do it sure
West Coast
yes cook
trying to get my pockets bigger than a
thick boy Swagger's so lit and probably
make you sick boy if you're looking for
the wave this is it me and Griffin had
to flip it to some old school [ __ ]
what's up brother
how you doing man long time no see my
fave
yeah man appreciate you
um I will you know what you want
you want me to go first so you know what
you want
um I want a couple things
Connecticut roll yes Lobster grilled
cheese Savage
and some lobster bisque
and I'll do uh two Connecticut rolls and
lobster bisque with extra Lobster please
yep
that's it brother appreciate Man
favorite truck
[Music]
that boy big as [ __ ]
tell me why you're so thick boy
don't you work out enough
[Music]
that booty white is a truck and even
though we give you [ __ ] boy
we still gotta get it up
all right let's take a little break from
me just talking to my boy Mike Perry
about fighting in beer knuckle fighting
the dude's insane but listen
we got to keep the house lights on here
at thick Boy Studio so we're gonna take
a little break because I'm here to talk
to you about that time you got hacked
maybe got a data breach maybe some
identity theft it's not fun it's a
digital world and we are some digital
girls so you gotta protect your stuff
I'm always concerned about filling stuff
out online that's just just this 2022 so
you're filling out all sorts of
important uh private information on your
phone wherever you're at and you got to
protect yourself that's where my friends
at all state identity protection got you
covered the best identity protection
from a brand you can trust you've heard
of Allstate all right the internet knows
that way too much about us but it
doesn't have to with Allstate digital
footprint see a list of your online
accounts track where you've been online
learn how companies are using your data
if your personal information has been
exposed in a data breach and get tips to
proactively protect your privacy
identity it's 2022. you want to make
sure you're covered online and Allstate
identity protection even includes dark
web monitoring that's right even on the
dark web we got you covered with with an
eye Ai and human Source intelligence
providing an extra layer of detection
with AIP they'll reimburse you up to 1
million buckaroos for out-of-pocket
expenses lost wages legal fees also
cover money stolen from your bank
accounts 401ks hsas and tax returns not
only will all state monitor to help keep
you covered and keep you safe but should
identity theft ever occur their us-based
customer service identity Specialists
provide expert supports 24 7 3 and 65
days a year and they have a 98
satisfaction score we got you man all
right what I love about Allstate
Allstate identity protection is my whole
family's covered I have peace of mind I
can go to Starbucks I can go any coffee
shop I can do this in the freaking
airport I'm putting out I'm buying stuff
I'm putting my info out there I don't
worry about it because I'm covered with
Allstate all right so when you think
identity protection think Allstate
identity protection to find out if your
employer offers all state identity
protection head to aip.com if not you
get 30-day free trial at aip.com one
last time that's aip.com
protect yourself this episode of food
truck diaries with the one and only Wild
Man Mike Perry is brought to you by the
best Kratom on the planet listen cram's
the wild west like CBD back in the day
but now you can trust my friend that
happy hippo it's the only creative I use
I use their highly concentrated Cherry
shots before I go on stage before I do
podcasts whatever I'm doing it's the
best focused product you ever try all
right and here's the thing it's all
natural if you think about trading
Kratom try it with my friends at happy
hippo visit
happyhippo.com use promo code dickboy
for 25 for Life use that code as many
times as you want share it with your
friends family your aunt your new
adopted brother whoever it is 20 for a
life all you gotta do is go to
happyhippo.com use promo code thick boy
for 20 off for life now let's get back
to the program my mail is dig in they
got your food there you got your tequila
now I offered you some tiger thick even
drinking tequila so we don't want to mix
cheers brother cheers next time yeah
we get you on campaign we go heavy on
the whiskey get pretty wild on here
Orlando's far trip though huh to here
what five hour flight oh it's not bad on
a one-way yeah
slap most of it I guess since I woke up
early
still getting these lobsters yeah no
doubt hopefully you enjoy them I'm sorry
they're my favorite I think I will hot
second
I knew we had to line up a special truck
that came too far not to I appreciate it
I've I've uh you know through all the
weight Cuts I've been in
I've always wanted to like you know be
on a TV show eating food
trying it out now do you uh did you have
to worry about your weight at all for uh
beer knuckle
um
when it gets close I fight at 75 so I
get that five pound allowance Now with
uh
from fighting at 170 for so many years
but
I mean when I made my Pro debut it was
at 155 and then I got a little bigger a
little older
a little harder the 175 I try to
pump a little more iron be a little
stronger yeah a little thick boy yep and
uh
it doesn't take much though for me I
mean I'm probably sitting pretty big
right now my grown man's status I'm at
like 195. damn
solid 195 and
I feel like my cardio is in my my head
yep as long as I stay calm yep and um
and you know when to explain as soon as
I start dieting eating clean chicken and
stuff like that I'll be 180 in no time
so I'm only cutting like 10 pounds when
I'm fighting bare knuckle that's not bad
at all 175. you're in your cardio
especially in that I'll give it a page
fight man that was a
when I went to the scorecards do you
think they would give it to you
I thought so at the end of five I
thought they were gonna screw it yeah
when they did because did they mention
anything in the back room out a bonus
round
um I knew it was in the contract oh
really I had talked about it that week
actually on a couple of interviews I had
said
he responded and said you don't go to
draw with me okay I was like I'm gonna
be in your face for five rounds they're
gonna call a sixth round
I kind of said in the Julian Lane fight
too I was like you know I'm prepared for
a sixth round
and um
but
at the end of the fifth I went back to
my corner I mean my thing with the bare
knuckle is every time I go back to the
corner
I know I gotta go tow the line again
so I was like you know the the cut man's
like doing a couple adrenaline Q-tips on
my forehead and then I'm like fighting
him getting him out the way like I gotta
go back out there I gotta get there
before he does I want to get on that
line before my opponent does and now
that I'm saying it the next guy might
try to do it to me I ain't gonna care no
yeah because I know I'm I'm ready to
fight at all times when I go to get in
the ring I was prepared to be on that
line I was prepared not to not stop in
between rounds you know what I mean so
you're old school
you're an old school fighter I am a
little bit older people in life period
yeah I'm like you know I ride my bike to
your house and knock on your door and
your mom answers I'm like damn what are
your son trying to leave a message on
the answer machine like this is 2022. I
said I didn't even use the phone back
then I just pulled up on my bicycle hell
yeah you know and you grew up how that's
pretty good when you grow up how because
you're so goddamn tough unless you got a
wild side too you grow up give me a
little back story on your childhood
uh two-hand touching the street tackling
the grass football
um basketball
ride my bike 20 miles a day all over the
place crossing the main roads
uh walk the school in kindergarten
talking about
blocks used to run from dogs in the
morning because they would get out of
their yard little Chihuahuas this is
what city you grew up in Flint Michigan
oh damn yeah
and then I mean Apopka Florida too back
and forth between parents
um good childhood
I think so yeah it's all relative yeah
it's like you know I was a young kid
just like had the whole world in front
of me and like I may have had things or
didn't have things that other kids had
and I never cared I don't care what
somebody else has that I don't have I'm
not looking at that I was just trying to
enjoy my life and be happy yeah overall
good childhood though yeah I think so
and your parents are proud of you now
where you become what you what you do
they kind of like that face tap right
um
man you know my Dad tried to get me
before I got my first tap was my name
Mike on my titties that was it it was
just Mike his dad's like what are you
gonna forget your name that's the joke
my dad would give me yeah you know he
had maybe a little bit of jokes but he
he liked me no matter what I did yeah no
matter what my dad supported me all the
time and my mom just didn't want to see
me be like my dad
so she was hard on me when I was younger
and I never gave my mom any problems you
know I always gave her respect um
and um you know now I'm the man of the
house Mama lives with me you know I'm
grateful everything is really flipped
yeah the other way no I'm proud of you
man thank you and it's uh you know when
you say your mom didn't you your dad
fighter too tough guy because we're I'm
trying to get to it where the hell does
this toughness come from you're like
this old school dude like you should've
been fighting in the 20s like this and
[ __ ] with bare Knuckles you know what
I'm saying like that that's the vibe you
give my dad is still the toughest dude
I've ever seen in my life he's a
psychopath he's crazy guy man he's so
old now but he's like he's got veins
bulging out all over the place and like
his his neck is like swollen with veins
and he's just he's everything he says is
just so angry sounds yeah it takes a lot
of energy for him to talk don't you he
loves it yeah he's always been like an
aggressive dude that's definitely where
it comes from there it is it's a Perry
thing yeah and what that's messy are you
what are you um
man if you didn't know man I'm
everything no because like my son is
Mexican so I'm Mexican my my um they say
I'm Nigerian because I got a little bit
a tiny tiny bit of African you know I'm
related to Francis and Izzy it shows you
know weiner
um from the waist down on the waist down
um I got you know and you know that
black athleticism yeah I grew up around
that man these guys no I mean no
disrespect you guys are [ __ ] athletic
bro so I don't think that's
disrespectful I'm a little I'm a
Caucasian I'm an Indian I'm African I'm
Mexican you're a real mutt
yeah I'm a real mutt man I'm an American
oh there you go cheers way to finish
that off yeah I would have never I mean
if you gave me 20 guesses like white
white white white white right you know
a lot of girls think I'm Spanish
are you part Spanish yeah I get that all
the time no I'm white man like all white
boy my mom born and raised in England
have you ever done it though like
23andMe I did it in case they sent me a
chart mayonnaise man
no my so my mom's uh born and raised in
England so I'm 50 English my dad's
German Italian that's where the dark
comes from so I was friends in German
British and Irish 24 24 24 24 24 24 and
then just a splash of African yeah it's
like just a splash but a drop damn yeah
I think we all have that drop though
yeah they think we all have that you do
yeah bring my own and your kids are you
said your kids are Mexican my son is
Mexican yeah I'm Mexican too they're on
the way that's congrats brother dogs I
mean my baby Mama's skin is just the
prettiest skin out there
now what kind of Mexican we're talking
about we're talking about like Taco Bell
Mexican are we talking like legit
Guadalajara Mexican you know what I'm
talking about like
well her family is definitely legit
Mexican she's a Texas white girl yeah
little brown girl's body and
um I mean she don't speak no Spanish
less than me and I don't speak no
Spanish I know UMass than she does yes
so
um but
bro your kids are gonna be a nightmare
if they have your tenacity and they have
the Mexican oh dude game set match my
son's not even two he's just screaming
if he's looking for sparring partners
they have two-year-old he's big he
doesn't want to fight well he's two
he already knows oh yeah he does not
want I think he'll change his mind or
not I don't want him to fight no I don't
either but they're drawn to it yeah this
for me
dada's gonna take the punches I got
everybody's back and I'm never gonna
stop doing this so even if you started
fighting [ __ ] I'd still be knocking
kids out before you even got started
doing this [ __ ] so you guys go learn
some crypto [ __ ] on the computer and
figure out how to get some real estate
or something
go talk to your friends at school all
right don't [ __ ] fight
yeah I don't want my kids just more my
son woke up at 5 30 first and he does
get the boxing gloves he's like Papa I'm
like I post my on my story I'm like well
5 30 just boom boom boom about my bro
kids don't grow up I'll tell you what
though
he's a little bit destined to take
punches to the head or things like that
because I see him hit his head all the
time and all this stuff he just Falls
and I'm like oh man I'm trying to
protect you from this yeah you're just
kind of going towards it on your own I
know that means you're his dad he might
find that Splash for Mexican that kid
set up for Success
you and I coach him up no obese man all
right kids another break then we're
right back into it with Mike Perry Just
chomping on down some lobster roll so my
friends at Cousins Lobster food truck my
favorite food truck but here's the thing
like man Brennan is zoned in on this
episode what is going on with him he
looks really dialed in well I'm I'm
gonna tell you right now I'm on to my
Alpha Brain the best nootropic on the
planet you've heard about nootropics
you've read about them like I don't know
who to try it with do they work they
work Alpha Brain Works they've sold over
1 million bottles because it works if
you're gonna trust anyone trust my
friends out on it alright and Alpha
Brain these nootropics they help your
memory your cognitive functions all
right you're under stress to help you
get your job done better all right uh
listen Joe Rogan you ever heard of him
he swears by Alpha Brain it says it
helps them form better sentences when
he's talking be more like him all right
Alpha Brain contains amino acids and
plant compounds that promote the brain's
release of alpha waves so you're firing
all cylinders we got you a matter of
fact on it so positive you're gonna love
it you have a money back guarantee no
refund necessary keep it give it to your
friends who they're they might like it
you're ungrateful bastards but anyways
on it has a no return necessary refund
so we got you covered if you're worried
about caffeine caffeine free save your
excuse try the best nootropic on the
planet Alpha Brain by going to audit.com
job you save 10 off the entire on it
website workout gear Warrior bars elk
bars protein powders fish oils battle
ropes kettlebells we got you covered on
it.com
everything or you can pick up just Alpha
Brain at your local Walmart
but also help your boy out good on
it.com shop you're welcome let's get
back to the program yeah so back to
business for you business is good man I
think you know when you're saying you
don't think you got the the recognition
or the kind of the
I don't know the respect you deserve
over that microphone and Page fight I
think you're and listen everybody's
wired this way I'm wired this way I know
that's why I don't really mess with
social media but you don't get a hundred
positive comments but the one negative
one you're we're wired to focus for to
protect ourselves you're focused on the
negative I think you got like even here
you know I I forget who's on the show
we're talking about legit Fighters I'm
like damn Mike Mike showed he you know
world class man like and I feel you know
obviously Twitter's gonna Twitter but in
general I felt like you had a ton of
respect for me like and I know
especially the UFC side of things from
what I've seen the fans like hell yeah
like most of them were rooting for you
against Michael Bennett page right I'm
grateful for that uh I've built a little
bit of a fan base and I'm super grateful
for it uh for the ones that support and
the ones who are Hot Heads that talk
[ __ ] I mean I'm obviously
if they didn't talk about me I wouldn't
be out there but I'm out there and um
you know I think about things like the
trailer fight that I had against that
boxer
that was that was big time for me I
trained harder for that than I've done
for any fight ever I was in better shape
because I was excited to fight a 25-3
pro boxer and um and that was for seven
two minute rounds and
you know with the Michael Venom page
fight you know I kind of know a little
bit about mixed martial arts and I'm
like as much as you know he's had
success in some boxing
I know a karate guy you know he's not
gonna outbox me he's not gonna out fight
me yeah you know and I'm I'm there for
that so
I kind of saw that coming
uh I didn't you know do it the way I
wanted I didn't finish him didn't get
him out of there I'm hoping I'm hoping
to keep building towards that and get
him on the next one but some sometimes I
think it's like in the Jake Paul fight
like I think he got more respect from
the fight Community I know he said he
don't care about it but he does he got
more respect than a fight to me by
beating Silva by decision so if he would
have started in the first 30 seconds or
if you would have starch microphone page
and I compare you guys you're I'll see
your resumes a lot more impressive and
been doing a lot longer but what I'm
saying there's a comparison here where
if you were to start my component page
in 30 seconds or he starts to answer
something 30 seconds people go I
actually just sold out Michael Van Pace
he's getting older man okay so you don't
get the credit but when it goes rounds
and you see no it's not an older Michael
Venom page Mike Gray's out fighting him
he's he's out maneuvering him he's out
boxing him with Jake Paul no he just
didn't starch him he out boxed him for
eight rounds you know what I'm saying so
yeah I think it does more for you guys
in the long term and when the fans over
to get them to acknowledge your real
talent I get what you're saying
um
someone was talking to me recently about
this about you know if fights are rigged
sometimes and things like that someone
in the sports like a random fan
Fighters wish fights were rigged yes
okay
they're not no there Comes A Time in
your life as a fighter when you're like
man I want to call my opponent and be
like bro I'll lay down because just give
me a little extra on the check
because you don't know if you're gonna
win or not anyway yeah I tried doing no
gear he don't speak English
fights are not rigged there's no way in
hell they're rigged it's just some one
side might know that they got it and the
other side doesn't and uh it's not
Reagan Ben actually has said it best he
was like I know a lot of people you know
say the fight with me and Jake Rodriguez
it's so stupid he was so short-sighted
he goes you know how much more money I
would have made by beating Jake Paul
because then I get his brother then
maybe buy you a counter fighter Nate
Diaz like I lost I got knocked out No
One's Gonna fight me now so it's a short
side yeah I made good money but I would
make sense
just can't box and all yeah so but he
said that he was on food truck maybe
that's my next fight Ben Ben make your
comeback in boxing
fight me bro I think that's good but
then he was on food truck I think two or
three weeks before that fight he said
I'll be honest with you man he's like if
he bought if he can't if he turns out he
can actually box I'm screwed I'm getting
knocked up you because I just don't
think you Embark sometimes think in box
you learn the hard way you know we find
out you know and I know you want to
fight Jake but you got to respect what
he's doing right a little bit yeah
absolutely having me just beat Anderson
Silva one of the best champions in UFC
history
and we know Silva to have hands
but I was there I was front row oh were
you I just didn't see silver boxing him
like I thought Silver could box you did
early on I didn't see any distance
jabbing I thought you know he would cut
Jake off and he would trap him in the
corner and he would only try to fight
him once he got him closed off and he
would only get a couple shots and Jake's
constantly moving thinking about defense
and protecting himself
yeah
I just I was like Wow after the second
round I was like oh I see where this is
going Jake Jake stayed on his point game
faint faint jabbed to the body faint
switch over left hook and move around
the ring yep draw him in
I can see that I mean
I know boxing yeah I love boxes it would
be a great opportunity to fight Jake I
would love the opportunity because it's
about the same size I mean he's actually
quite bigger than me he's taller he's
closer to your size no no no he's my boy
Logan's more my size Jake I'd say I
don't care how big he is no I'm just
saying I don't care how small he is how
big he is I know he's bigger than me
because silver fought at 85 as the
champion at 85 for years that's always
been much bigger than me I was in the
UFC as a welterweight at 170 85 seemed
like such a leap because those guys were
200 coming down a lot of them even
bigger than 200 yeah some are bigger
than that and then too at 170 they're
even way taller than big boys yeah yeah
so yeah I mean I was one of the smallest
welterweights
yeah
right I'm thick yeah a little bit so you
know I stay low to the ground and that's
where all the power comes from but you
know I think a fight versus you and Jake
will be super entertaining and I would
be willing to bet I'd put a good amount
of money on it does more pay-per-view
sales than Anderson Jake well I know he
wouldn't finish me and it's all about um
over there hey I disagree I think one of
you would get finished with your style
and his style because Jacob played that
game you sure finishing me he can hit me
with good shots because he's hit me with
him before I sparred him he's got the
footage oh you smart him yeah he's got
the holidays
is right before I fought uh it was right
before he fought
ice cream and it was right before I
fought Rodriguez oh so your last fight
in UFC and then it was his kind of first
official fight boxing yeah
it was in Miami and how'd that go
he hit me with some great shots in the
beginning and I ate them like I do
that's what I do and I'll tell you what
I was grappling that morning I mean no
no excuses my boxing isn't what it was
it wasn't what it is now my box and now
I'm focused on boxing back then
I was grappling that morning and
um you know with that d-rod fight you
know when I fought Danny Rodriguez I was
at the gym great fighter can't believe
Neo magni got him the way I feel like
you imagine the most winningest of all
time yes that's my name is amazing man
I've always wanted the opportunity to
fight that guy Neil magni good Fighter
um I think I have the skills and I
understand his his length and his
distance and all of that I feel like you
know as a fighter when you come up
around these guys you watch them you
learn how to fight against that correct
um
but you know Jake hit me with a couple
shots they were getting excited for him
but
I get hit you know and yeah especially
back then that's what I was going to say
is when I was getting ready for D Rod I
was smoking guys in the gym with
Superman Jabs and Superman punches and
and once I land one shot on you you know
they they can't figure out where to go
and then I can do whatever I want
whether it be combination head body head
or trip them down to the ground a ground
and pound
when I fought d-rod I didn't land one of
those attempts on him I I attempted a
Superman jab or punch about
four or five times and what do you think
that is not one of them hit him they got
close but they didn't hit him yeah he
understood boxing a little better at
that time
yes drockbox and he's longer he's a
little taller and he knew I was boxing
and one thing he threw me off with was
his leg kick his inside leg kick and he
was at Southpaw his inside leg kick tore
up my leg a little bit more than I
thought it would I thought his little
skinny legs weren't going to do that to
me but his little bony foot was hurting
my kneecap pretty bad yeah and it was
slowing me down so I couldn't really
close the gap
but now just boxing you've gotten a lot
better but I'm assuming back then you
know you and Jake have both got a lot
better at boxing right like you both won
so much better but I just saw him I just
saw him fight Silva and um
yes he stayed on his game the whole time
fainting the moving playing the distance
um working the ring you know running
around in circles and uh we also see him
take some shots too which is what I but
he had no pressure game
is from what I saw I mean
I know he like even when he kind of
acted like he was coming at Silva it was
just to draw Silver to come into him and
then he would back up and try to counter
and the way I fight you know I'm kind of
like Mike Tyson I go for it I go in I
slip off I slip and rip I get to the
side and I try to hit you with
devastating shots in in devastating
areas and um and you think you'd be able
to do it against Jake absolutely yeah I
would because I did it I mean my
pressure started adding up yes he hit me
with shots early
um but you expect them going in though
because there's a thing to it where it's
like I kind of wanted to feel it yeah I
was like I know this kid can hit I want
to feel that Jake Paul punch right and
he hit me from the outside with that
sneaky right hand and uh it's like okay
and I just kept my pressure on my one
thing about me you go ask Eric Anders I
told you me and him sparked yeah I love
it he's way bigger than me
my pressure never stops he hits me he
hit me with shots I should have put guys
to sleep I might stumble for a second
but then I'm right back in your face
work in the box and working the
technique that I'm working you're almost
like I know your kids are Mexican your
wife is Mexican there's there has to be
some spot I'd do your 23andMe again
because it has to be some Mexican
because you fight like a Mexican I'm
definitely old school Mexican I'd go 100
man like Chavez senior would love you if
you if we just show them your fight film
because that's how he fought that's how
Canelo fights but you know one thing
about the best fighters out there is
they don't give a [ __ ] about nobody else
so that's how I feel too is that if I'm
trying to build something for myself and
for my family I don't care who supports
and who doesn't just put me in the ring
and give me the opportunity and and I
love that about because that that's
growth right because for a while I felt
like you were paying attention to that
[ __ ] yeah right almost too much yeah
I was like where's my chairman yeah
they're doing it to get a rise out here
we need to have issues outside of
fighting like at a restaurant whatever
I'm like well people know like if they
if they poke the the bear with the face
tat he's gonna respond you know I still
do do ya yeah
no people still get me
he's like nah I still light them up they
still get me man
Call of Duty oh I suck at that [ __ ] I
gotta accept that but they still pissed
me off sometimes you should do yeah my
gamer tag is smashy Mob because I suck
so bad and when people talk [ __ ] to me
I'm like I already [ __ ] your mom
it's okay it's all right
but but it'll still get to even even on
the streets I feel like people don't
mess with you anymore especially if they
saw because here's the thing about you
were talking about maybe maybe the low
numbers on the mic event we'll get to
that the low numbers I'm Mike Evan and
Paige fight but remember we live in a
digital world where everyone's consuming
material on in the short bit so yeah
maybe I don't know let's say it did 300
000 buys or whatever but remember the
clip of you rocking him on that you're
talking about millions
millions and millions people saw that
millions of people so they know you beat
them up even though they didn't pay for
the pay-per-view in the grand scheme of
things millions and millions of people
know you whooped his ass that's the
thing about fighting we're going in
there for a highlight
whoever's got the best highlight at the
end of the fight is probably the winner
in the fans eyes yeah most of the time
we get Nate Diaz Leon Edwards he got
beat up for a bunch of rounds yeah last
30 seconds but then all the fighters
know what Leon did for 25 minutes the
fighters know the fan base they they
don't yell them down he controlled him I
know what Leon does in all of his fights
by is the champion right now he controls
every moment of the fight
and unfortunately against Camaro he
didn't no and that's why he lost the and
then fight to the heck but he never
stopped trying to beat Camaro so then he
got him I guess man you know and they
can do the rematch
do you still follow UFC yeah of course
everyone does I mean I watched the good
ones uh
waiting on John's return you think he
comes back are you a fan of John love
John me too I think he's the best we've
ever had hands down man you want to
fight John hell yeah I don't care if he
kills me I'm gonna [ __ ] try to get
his ass I feel like that's good yeah I
feel like he's gonna tough hey can bleed
I win yeah okay I win I make him bleed
he you know he might take it one way but
I love John yeah how can you not he's
the best he's the reason I met my baby
mama and my wife please explain the
story
we were walked in there oh because did
you still used to be at Jackson's yeah I
was there for a bit taught me a little
lesson what lesson John teach you you
know he said
oh we're back now listen I've been at
Jackson I love John he's my he's the
greatest five all the time we know he's
a wild boy you know John is he's he's a
white boy in every capacity I think
that's what makes him so special and
that's why
he has to stay away from
you know the the youthful mindset
because
we all want to be young again and we
can't grow up it's Father Time father
time plus you have kids it's father time
to be father correct you know the other
time on Father time yeah for sure what
did he tell you where you met your wife
ah what I went to the club to go hang
out with him drink a little um
yeah it was just them and like because
the club was dead I was early I'm always
early to stuff you know you got to go to
the club late
for people to be there so I walked in
and he's like
and he brought us together and I just
saw this little thing this little love
at first Spanish girl and her leopard
skirt
I picked her up it was Simba yeah yeah
let's get out of here damn good thing
came early so John's really the reason
why my married wife yeah shout out to
Jon Jones shout out to John I mean love
me I mean we want we actually want him
to um appreciate the wedding marry us
yeah you think he'll do it I mean I bet
he would I'm calling him out over here
he might not yeah he'll see this I mean
you have to go to Albuquerque to do it
I was thinking Mexico is where we would
do it maybe I paid for a trip for him to
come down and bring his family and he
just officiate the wedding
yeah I like this and so but you're not
Jackson's anymore now especially now
you're doing business I haven't been
there for years I did that I fought
twice there so I went good experience
for you I went in a short period
I had the uh Paul Felder fight I was
still pretty fresh out of Orlando I feel
like my boxing at that time is what won
me that fight with Felder Paul fell is a
hell of a fighter but work in the midst
that I did at Jackson's
um you know that helped but yeah Felder
was just tough he was just so tough
great analyst too smart so tough smart
guy man and it was a heck of an
opportunity to fight against him and I
came away with the the decision that's a
big win man yeah and then
man just something told me you know I
was in Orlando I was living my best life
I was up in the in the high rise and and
then um
people came back and were like
I was getting the cowboy fight and they
were like come back because he left come
back to train the Jacksons and I was
just something was like you know damn
you know there's so many things in the
past and I just wish I
just went done it differently and why
didn't you do it
I went back to Jackson's I just went
back for camp Oh I thought when I felt
like I should have stayed in Orlando
with the best Jiu Jitsu guys that we
have we got the best Brazilian Jujitsu
guys in Orlando man Rodolfo Vieira
Jacquees Souza Liotta Machida we got all
these guys
these guys on a daily basis yeah
my Jiu Jitsu is sick
but I took him down and got my [ __ ]
arm snatched you know it's good from the
bottom cowboy was a tricky guy man
Cowboys guarded people don't realize his
guard is world class world class oh he's
one of the best people don't know
practitioners in the UFC history they
don't know he could grapple with
Oliveira easily yeah yeah I came up with
Cowboys they're both of them I was
always thought to myself man he should
take more guys down cement I feel like I
feel like you know
I want to see
because I know I got Jiu Jitsu it's been
a while I'm a little rusty you don't
show it either though Islam marketev you
know if he took me down
I feel like I take his back yeah yeah
tough task yeah but he's a little
smaller so I got a little oh that's yeah
he is 55 right yeah and look at him
trying to fight a smaller guy well get
out of here with the damn 45 pounds get
the [ __ ] out of here with that it's a
business find a thrill fight fight
another guy who can wrestle with you and
compete with you uh Islam should be
fighting guys like like Leon Michael
Chandler or King kumaru yeah those are
70 Pounders you want me to go up he
probably still beats them too he's a
problem he's read that Russian wrestling
I just was in in Russia didn't you I was
just there myself
what happened out there explain that man
what happened um
I feel like trying I saw a video on the
Russian where they do those face-offs
and they're always knocking people out
oh I saw somebody beat up some dude just
got choked out on the couch press
conference yes they all gonna he was
gonna die yeah it's Russia right I was
ready for that [ __ ] I soon since we
walked into this the studio I was like
oh I've seen this place Mike let me let
me ask you let me ask you this though so
why did you go to Russia your buddy was
fighting yeah and you're cornering
and Russia's the middle of War right and
you're like yeah let's go there
I guess they're not getting bombed
they're doing the bombing
but still you know you know if my
brother's a kid I'm going to Russian way
have fun it ain't happening now you
didn't care you know what sucked is that
we were once we were there then it got a
little scary also because the news
dropped like Fox and CNN was like oh all
Americans leave Russia immediately yeah
and then family and my girls are texting
me this [ __ ] like my girls calling me
crying and screaming like get the [ __ ]
out of there you have a family yeah what
shoe size you wear man you're trying to
[ __ ] leave it yeah you're like my
friend has a job we came here yeah to do
something and your friend was fighting
what and then and then
cares what this organization was called
you know the day before the fight yeah
I'm the manager the promoter the
contract negotiator I was writing the
contract with pencil and paper in
English in English in Russia the day
before the fight like oh no shoes
no elbows no kicks no need but you know
what you're getting into right boxing
with four ounce gloves
in an MMA cave that's Russia dude online
there's like there's many things
fight each other oh they trained it
before it was supposed to be an MMA
fight oh damn and he's a kicker welcome
to Russia he's a big kicker and they
took away he's boxing this boxer what
weight class
heavyweight oh
he's boxing this boxer at heavyweight
and he hasn't been boxed and he needs
his legs so dude he just did they [ __ ]
his mind did they agree to the rules or
he hit the Box
we agreed for a little bit more money
they got you yeah they got it I gotcha
they got you they got you because when
we started the show remember you're like
I'm not the business guy but then you're
you know I'm like you know I was talking
to my buddy like you know I know what
you came here for
you got to go out there and fight this
guy you know if you want to box him you
get this money it's easy just four ounce
cause you [ __ ] hit him easy work
that's it easy don't let him hit you and
you hit him and
did that coach he looked good on the
mids I just felt like I wished I would
have tried to hit him in the back a
little faster or a little harder I wish
I would have tried to hit him do you
think that would make the difference no
because the thing is the dude hit him
with a shot that people don't [ __ ]
get up from ever again oh yeah upper
cutter and he got the [ __ ] up over
overhand right from this clean 260 he he
weighed in 220 and his opponent weighed
in 250. sounds like a bad deal yeah
both I mean a lot of juice going on oh
we're not it's Russia but also what did
you guys expect
it's Russia bro dude you thought they
were gonna be like okay but I expect him
it's Russia bro
they don't play nice they don't play
well you know what the thing was man the
mental game of it was like they had my
boy afraid
to think that if he won what's going to
happen to us
no excuse yeah but I still don't fight
in Russia though right yeah like overall
definitely I mean Julian Lane went out
there got slept right after that he sure
did because he thought you know what was
I told him at the fights the other night
I was in bare knuckle in Orlando I said
man I think that you were more careless
because you had the gloves on yep even
though it's a bigger punch when I fought
you you were so afraid to get hit by me
with bare Knuckles you were [ __ ]
defensive all over the place
and the gloves on you were just like
hands down
gloves don't mean but you hit harder
with gloves on 100 yeah you have to hold
the padding everything so and then he
runs into the ring because he said he's
managing this guy who's fighting and the
his the guy's opponent the fight got
called because he head-butted them the
ref called the fight the guy tries to
fight him more so Julian runs into the
ring he said he was that guy's manager I
was like bro you have bad management yes
also again no offense but also Russia
right the guy's fighting managing it's a
[ __ ] show yeah they were trying to talk
me into a fight don't do that Mike no no
when I faced off with this guy they want
me to fight this Ismail Michael mob guy
yeah
they call him Maga I'm like you know
what Maga means make America great again
baby and nah that guy up and then
they're like posting pictures of it on
his Instagram like oh heavyweight pal
first of all [ __ ] I'm 178 pounds Max
when I'm like training
not a heavyweight that's just for your
information
so they're like I'm bad
oh yeah and they're trying to get the
fight done so is that why you popped off
yeah he likes trying to do [ __ ] he's all
up in my face get the [ __ ] out my face
he tries to hit me cousin talks about
his mother or whatever they try to jump
I said [ __ ] oh so they're like
oh what you say about my mother I'm like
okay you trying to jump me now [ __ ] get
back I'm running all over the place you
can't catch me yeah and then yeah you
know I was trying not to be a highlight
you weren't worried about what would
happen to you like the consequences
messing with these Russians when you
leave there
um
when I leave there what are they gonna
do here oh no no no I'm safe here now
I'm talking [ __ ] over here now but I'm
not talking too much [ __ ] because I know
I might have to go back one day because
they might make a real offer I'll go
back and fight they don't scare me a
bunch of white boys over there [ __ ] them
I'll go to Africa and fight I'll go to
Russia and fight I fight anywhere in the
world
I might need a little security [ __ ]
because if I fight fair I fight
one-on-one in the ring it's fair I just
want fair I'm trying to watch my own
back yeah you know
so then you're so that'll start because
the language Barry said [ __ ]
this also happened with uh Canelo they
know what he fights again they know they
know what else maybe maybe it's Rush
again I hate to keep saying this it's
Russia so it's you know it's tough for
them but maybe lay low on Russia for a
little bit unless the bare knuckle
doesn't find out they're not gonna make
a real offer anyways they're gonna make
an offer They're Gonna Change off as
soon as I get there I'm gonna be
discussing my own [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here
I ain't doing business like that my team
do real business yeah they doing real
numbers
I got a family yeah you gotta pay him
for them yeah we don't need to fight out
in Russia because I like I told you when
we started the show I think I would
imagine bear Knuckles trying to get your
bit because you can't go backwards like
you just beat Michael Venom page so now
it's like what's next
any idea you no no no no
no
no
no
listen
if you see me doing these select in this
lose to them celebrity boxing matches
businesses the the the shows just ate
[ __ ] I'm not selling tickets Mosley
no and he fought Mosley like a fake
fight it was a celebrity boxing I see
those are fake Mosley was shocked
really fighting Shaq he thought I don't
know what he thought he was going you
know you gotta look that up dude that
was years ago that's that's good times
damn like late 90s early 2000s now you
know they were doing before the Jake
Paul's of the world and all that like
Shaq and Mosley you know uh Lyle azado
played for the Denver Broncos retired he
fought Muhammad Ali at Mile High Stadium
instead of boxing like they've been
doing these circuits [ __ ] up he didn't
do terrible really he was like an old
how about the Uriah Hall versus Le'Veon
see I thought I thought Uriah Hall just
needed to bend his knees and he would
have knocked him out I know because if
he just bent his knees a little bit and
let his hands go but I don't know what
Uriah was doing I thought that was more
of a win even though you're uh Le'Veon
Bell lost my decision it was more of a
win for Le'Veon Bell I mean props to
leave you on hell yeah
it looked a little bit like treontay
wilder beast the dry Hall is a Savage so
I was like oh Lehman belt [ __ ] up I
mean he's got some of the best knockouts
you've ever seen and if he's straight
here you're in trouble man and I mean he
he picked apart Anderson correct before
we thought that it could be done really
yeah remember his wheel kick an ultimate
fighter they're called one of the best
knockouts that's what I'm saying so so
for you it's it's kind of you know you
can't go anywhere but forward you got
Michael Venom page right you got that
win it's an outsider I still feel like
I'm climbing so you take a guy like
Uriah Hall I like Uriah respecting him
but I feel like he's a little all over
the place at this point now in his life
and his career and we're retired and
then I think this came out of the blue
right like he said he was depressed
after all that so me
I've been telling myself and everybody
else for years that there's nothing else
I'm ever going to do this is it for me
so I've dived in and I just feel like
I'm in a better place
in a winning mindset and and I know when
I go into the ring I'm kill or be killed
yeah you gotta take me out otherwise I'm
all over you trying to cut you open make
you bleed I'm trying to fight you yup I
have no other way to fight and you know
when when uh your eye Halls talk about
depression stuff like that I think a lot
of that has to do with you know his wins
and losses did you get into depression
when the UFC cut you
got the Rodriguez fight did you did it
how did it feel for you you were cool it
was quick it was it wasn't a cut
yeah I could just finish it my dumbass I
thought that I had another fight I don't
know why I thought that maybe I got
rocked that day I don't [ __ ] know but
I remember thinking before the fight
happened that I had one more fight on my
contract and then I went out and fought
and I then I found out that I didn't
because I thought I saw in a five fight
contract but it was a four fight
contract I don't know why I thought that
but but usually the negotiate before
your last fight they always make you an
offer so you don't become a free agent
well they were telling me UFC will
resign you you're gonna have to wait
uh wait how long do they say to the so I
fought d-rod
it was like you know before the end of
the year it was before November and I
was trying to fight again in like
November and you don't want to wait I
didn't want to wait I was trying to
fight by November and they wanted me to
wait till February
and nine months you know right now I'm
trying to get a fight by like January
if not anytime before the end of the
year January February I would like
January I would like to open up the year
and give the world something in the
beginning of the year a platinum Perry
event kick the 2023 off yeah kick that
[ __ ] off Michael Jordan [ __ ] yeah I like
that for sure
um no I want to finish on this tell me
if there's a true story this way around
the water cooler being the boys were
talking about this
especially in the UFC when WME and Ari
Emmanuel bought the UFC they held a like
a meeting for the fighters and you're at
that meeting and Ari Emmanuel sat next
to you in a suit and he didn't know who
he was
and you're like what the [ __ ] no he
wasn't in a suit
um
2017 uh Fighters Retreat yeah fighter
Summit yeah yeah and I'm just you know
we're at the buffet up top no one else
is allowed in there but the fighters and
I grabbed my food plate my buffet or
whatever and I sit down and then this
guy sits across from me and you got no
idea and then this girl fighter sits
across from me because she's like all
activists for like Fighter
um pay and she was talking to the army
manual I was like
yeah and like I'm over here like yeah
I'm just trying to fight and like get
paid bro like yeah and [ __ ] [ __ ] up you
know so did you have a conversation with
him yeah I'm like I don't know who you
are
I'm pretty sure you're supposed to be
important
he's like you know I'm about to join it
he said I bought the joint yeah I said
oh well don't say it like that I also
don't call it a joint it's my business
poor Bill yeah
yeah I had no idea what I was sitting
across from yeah yeah big boy nah most
powerful man in Hollywood but that's
what kind of maybe intrigued him about
me I'm sure it was like even once he
told me I didn't give a [ __ ] bro
I was like I'm just gonna fight people
that was when
that night I was playing cornhole with
Max Griffin I pushed Jeremy Stevenson to
the ground of playing cornhole Max
Griffin and he's like I'm gonna [ __ ]
fight you someday I'm like all right
[ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] you up and then he
beat my ass in Orlando oh I mean we were
talking about Theo Vaughan was talking
about it third round I came out and I
was on his ass he's a good point fighter
Max Griffin I'll give it to him he
fought I didn't watch the Tim Dirty
Birds fight the other night but um yeah
you know I want fights back I don't know
if they matter if I could have a fight
back it'd be either
Jeff Neal or Cowboy because those are
the only kids that wasn't tough because
he's retired but Jeff Neal could get
Jeff now you have to come over the UFC I
just there's this thing I know you want
to get back to the UFC I just feel like
you're doing so well at bare knuckle
near the face I mean that's the face of
it I want to fight they just need to get
more meat to feed you they need more
famous meat to feed you
that's what they got to do give me a can
too I'll sit them I'll put them away
okay it should be pretty easy to get
your fight yeah but that's the problems
him on my last fight with the contract
you have one fight left so they're like
we want to make it
something and then we give something for
him to come back it's gonna be a big boy
fight it's lined up for everything all
otherwise it should be Bellator pfl and
UFC One champion should be arguing for
me to come and fight for them because a
lot of people want to see me back in the
UFC and I love the show yeah I love the
[ __ ] show I'm sure the UFC would have
you back and you're exciting fighter but
I think with bear knuckle you're a big
fight the Stars I saw Dana man I was at
a fight in Vegas
yeah I walked in the back Joe Rogan was
happy to see me also man you know that
makes me feel and then I saw Dana he was
like what's up man I was like oh
I want to come back and he was like
I was like what bro like what is that
what'd he saying he just made her look
I was like I want to come back man and
this is happening
no this is before see don't have a
different ball game now you're in
different
Stratosphere I was still winning I know
but not Michael Venom page yeah come on
now Bellator what's up I'll fight Venom
page in bellatorian MMA why hasn't this
been talked about because I'll strangle
him
well hopefully you get your your big
fight in January like you do when if I
bike we want you on here for a while
brother you're one of my face thank you
so much so much fun man for having me
continued success stay out of Russia
before we leave though
I the thing we do on food truck uh my
boys at suplex in Philly my boy Mike I
always get a shoot for the fighters so
that's why that's when you're in Russia
so I was harassing for your shoe size
you're just dodging you know bullets or
whatever and so
um
these are for you my man I said I need a
dope flashy shoe because my perry likes
to show out these are some these are
some fire kicks
somebody's Jordan Ones Freddie my man
thank you so much enjoy those my man
maybe we're those my next walk out beat
somebody's ass in this
take him off for you thank you so much
we got it brother Mike pair everybody
[Music]
Siri
the personification of aggression a true
Global Superstar the hottest property in
my time
this is
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding